[Music]
hey guys it's benefits of a G from GE
tracker and in this video I'm gonna do
things a little bit differently I wanted
to go over one of our tools and that was
um the money-making section of our site
because I feel like the level may not
use that
but I wanted to Train herblore to try
and make money that way to try and boost
my bankroll and the first thing we
wanted to do the only profitable way to
do that is to clean the herbs themselves
so my main focus was to get to level 50
and
then see how much meta me from that and
then later on I was gonna make
unfinished potions in a different video
but what I want you guys to know I know
I've said this before
I'm not really a you know a content
video maker you know this isn't
something that I usually do
especially you know kind of like a
progress video for old school so I did
kind of make some you know recording
mistakes I
didn't really I didn't really know how
to plan
where to record and you know how to talk
to you guys about this stuff you know
but I'm learning and you guys have been
really nice so far you know with your
responses and the score chat in the
comments and you know all that feedback
has been really you know helping me to
try and you know experiment with this
and try and learn how to do better at
this so I really appreciate you guys
sticking around and you know all the
great feedback so let's get right into
this all right guys before we get
started with the video I just want to
show you guys how to use this tool real
quick and to find the clean edge tool
all you have to do is click the
money-making section and then it'll be
under Urbo profit and then you be shown
a list of three different options you
can make money using the skill
but this tool it's pretty
straightforward
but it's really easy to lose money if
you're not you know if you're not paying
attention and if you're not use
correctly because I did make a mistake
using this as well and I'm recording
this out for the fact and one of the
mistakes I gonna pay attention to was
the trade volume and in the first video
that I put out for you guys I told you
guys that the lower the trade volume
Mountain has the more volatile that
price could be you know the more a
higher chance that that price is gonna
change
and you're not gonna have any control
over it so
if I wanted to start cleaning herbs for
profit I'm gonna look at two things the
first thing I'm going to look at is how
many people are selling this herb in a
given point in time and to do that I can
just click the selling quantity per hour
and it's going to show me a list of
items that's showing the highest
transaction volume to the lowest okay
now if you notice on the clean herb
section of this tool you're going to
notice the buying quantity per hour of
the cleaner of this is only 25 so
there's about 13 to 13 thousand of these
being sold at any given point in time
and there's only 25 buyers and again one
time so immediately right off the bat I
wouldn't touch this
and this regarding the approximate
profit you know if I don't even look at
this I wouldn't even I wouldn't even
touch this item because it's me
incredibly hard to sell this item back
when there's no one to buy the item and
basic economics says that if there's
more suppliers than
then it's in demand that prices gonna go
down so I can expect a loss on this now
if I want to look at the next item below
that now I'm gonna notice that there's a
significant
larger portion of buyers for this herb
so this would be something that maybe I
would want to clean and then I was
started looking at the approximate
profit to start comparing different
items so if I can clean over Nara we'd
maybe I'll clean there and our we'd
because it's making more money and
there's more buyers at any given point
in time than there was with the herb
previously so yeah that's that's pretty
much how to use this tool
you just have to click on the buying
quantities through the herbs to make
sure that there's you know there's
someone there to buy the herb off of you
and make sure that you're not gonna be
sitting at the grand exchange for 10
hours just to buy you know a batch of
these and
like I said
these prices have changed quicker than
any other item that I've ever worked
with and even though the prices were
minuscule in changes it was significant
enough for me to be cautious using this
tool because it was easy to lose money
if I held on to an item for too long and
it was already overpriced then more than
likely if I wait till the next day I'm
gonna start losing money if I try
selling the cleaners back on that so you
just have to pay attention to that and
then let's just get right back into it
alright guys we just finished the
druidic ritual quest so now I can train
her Bloor that takes me to well I only
clean
up WOM leave
to some dude I don't have any variety
right now so I'll come back to you guys
when I'm at a higher level maybe one
might like level 20 or 25
alright guys so that's level 20 herblore
now I can clean that I'm not gonna say
any of the names because I'm gonna
pronounce them wrong and you guys gonna
elect me but um let's see here how much
I can make with that
[Music]
okay so earlier I was only cleaning the
Guam leaves and I was only making about
3 to 5 GP per leaf but this is a huge
jump so I'm gonna go ahead and start
cleaning this herb right here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
all right that's 50 done
that was gonna be my goal for this video
it took me like a like a week to do this
but keep in mind I was training her
blower as I was flipping so I was only
doing this maybe about 15 to 30 minutes
a day every day
so if that's something you wanted to do
you could just afk and sit at the bank
and train herblore
but going into this I've never I've
never trained this skill like this
before so I didn't know what to expect
and I didn't I didn't know how long I
was I'm take to level up and it was
actually a lot quicker than I thought
especially if you're gonna use like
mouse keys or whatever like that
but I'm gonna go ahead and sell these
right now just see how much I got back
in total
okay so all my herbs sold at the grand
exchange and I got back about 230 K
which is in bed from only starting about
like 5 K Stern cash deck
if I wanted to get this done a lot I
probably could have gotten done within a
couple of hours but I just did this on
the side you know just maybe 15 to 30
minutes a day doing this but as it's
easier for you guys for the next video I
wanted to see how much money I can make
using our tool to make unfinished
potions because everybody knows that if
you make it on finish potion you know
it's a moneymaker but I wanted to see
how much money I could make and within a
span of 2 minutes I made 10 K so for the
next video I'm probably gonna sit at the
grand exchange and use that tool to see
how much you can make maybe in a couple
of hours because right now I'm only
sitting at about 3 million and it's
really painful for me because I'm not
used to sitting at such low capital and
I know maybe for something you guys this
is a lot but I want to start boosting my
bankroll as quickly as possible so I can
start making
bigger clips because I now have a
actually made a 600 K investment in an
item and
that item right now is facing a lot of
uncertainty so the price is fluctuating
quite a lot so in my head I'm ready
imagining that those that 600 K is
already gone
so I'm trying to so I have to try and do
something
in game that's not just focused on
flipping but a money-making method
that's gonna help me invest in flipping
so I can continue to grow that that
bankroll
so if you guys don't know like that's my
philosophy anything I do in game I
always just reinvested into merging so
that I can start flipping bigger amounts
of money you know a larger amount of
capital to start moving forward quicker
so that'll be the next video so stay
tuned for that hey you made tuned into
the video that's great you know even
though we've had this YouTube channel
for about two weeks you guys have been
so supportive and the feedback has been
incredible now we could have asked for a
better community and so in return we
wanted to do a giveaway
now
in order to win all I have to do is
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
then leave a comment down below with the
runescape name and then I'm gonna use a
random number generator to pick a random
winner who's gonna win this membership
on here
but I'm telling a little bit generous
you know I don't feel like maybe one
winners enough so if you want to leave
another comment down below
along with subscribing to this YouTube
channel cuz you have to be subscriber to
win
as long as well as your runescape name
because I have to trade you in-game
if you want to leave a comment down
below what you would do with this bond
you know I'll pick a winner on that
basis too and you don't have to say that
you'll be a member you could just say
that you'll sell this bond and grow your
account and another way you know
whatever interests me you know I'll pick
a winner that way as well
okay and you know just stay tuned for
our next video
this the winners for this video should
be announced in the next one with the
unfinished potions you know the second
part to this money-making series for
this one
so yeah so you know thank you guys so
much for the support make sure to
subscribe leave a comment down below you
know hopefully you guys win good luck
merging and until next time
you